Forty-two years after unbreakable encryption tools were first conceived
that allowed individuals to communicate in private,
they’ve finally gone fully mainstream.
“What’sApp has introduced a new level
of encryption.”
“Amazon’s Fire OS5 will offer full disc
encryption.”
“So encrypted, privacy protected, disappearing”
One milestone came in 2016,
when the world’s largest messaging service
announced it would offer default end to end encryption
on all communications.
“What’sApp messages can now only be read
by their intended recipients
and can’t be accessed by anyone else including
governments or What’sApp staff.”
Law enforcement and intelligence agencies
are still reckoning with this new reality.
For decades they demanded tech companies hand
over private data on their users,
sometimes without obtaining warrants.
So companies like Apple have changed their
policies,
making it so that individual users are the
only ones with the keys to their own data.
“Sayed Farook and and his wife Tashfeen
Malik opened fire.”
“Hours later they were in turn killed by
police...”
This new era of consumer privacy led to a
standoff in 2016,
when the FBI demanded access to an encrypted
iPhone
belonging to a terrorist from San Bernardino,
California.
The FBI wanted Apple to write software that
would weaken the iPhone’s built-in security.
Apple refused, telling authorities if the
company were to create such flawed software
that would work like a backdoor,
it would create opportunities for hackers
to steal private information.
What is at stake here is: Can the government
compel Apple to write software
that we believe would make hundreds of millions
of customers venerable around the world.
It is in our view the software equivalent
of cancer.
And yet there's plenty of consumer data that's
unencrypted and accessible by large tech companies.
From Facebook to Gmail, law enforcement can
still get a warrant to get a hold of your data.